so when was the concept of this form
this film born and when'd you come on
board the concept was formed around six
years ago and the Apollo connected with
our other producers at Whitehorse and
that's when Cassidy Hartman and Gina
Festa Nigel Sinclair and his team
started the journey
I joined around three years ago three
and a half years ago when I ran into
Roger and he told me he was working on
this project and he knew I was a Harlem
native and former music person and we've
been looking for something to
collaborate on and you know it was a
great team to join gene the narrative
arc of this film sort of reminds one of
the National Museum of african-american
history and culture so it starts with
the very base and then Rises and Rises
and Rises and this film starts with the
very beginning sort of the minstrel when
you move beyond Donaghy's that goes
words and takes us to Obama can you talk
a bit about your approach and how the
pieces all two came together with all
the footage and all the story well
that's a long story but so when the
Roger first approached me about the
project first he wasn't think about a
historical doc I say Wow then I have to
go through all the archive I mean all
the footage that we shot in a previous
year were like Amateur Night and then
the minute I saw Tallahassee Coast
between a war domi was gonna be um the
season I knew exactly that's gonna be
the framing because it was just so
powerful about race and politics then so
what my co-editor John Fisher I haven't
go through all their archival footage
chronologically because I think we have
to have a foundation of chronological
story and then you know so we it it's
thematic transition into it's the the
transition is always the tricky part how
we jump from past to present like the
Amateur Night to tallahassee Coates
rehearsal to the final performance so
that but I always knew the framing was
going to be the performance what was the
sort of historical pressure knowing it's
not historical dock but but the historic
pressure and importance to this place
how'd that play into your your approach
well I think that the the Apollo is like
our ground zero for us to then explore
and connect it to broader themes in our
journey as African Americans and and so
I think that the pressure was always to
find that seamless transition from the
tip to the to the meta of what is the
music giving voice to what is the comedy
you know coded with messages about that
then speak to what's happening
historically in this interesting time
line of 85 years of african-american
history which is a very challenging 85
years emotionally for our journey so
Robert thinking about sort of this
history in the song how did it don't
turn back now how did that get written
and how was lettuce he chosen the songs
of time but now we're just trying to
take the you know the the aspect of what
we're talking about of black people
being oppressed and still making amazing
art you know that's kind of how we do it
and I called on my friend well that the
song happened because I was playing the
cue the way I did a lot of my film
scores I like to have the director in
the room that music editors in the room
and I will create the soundtrack in
front of their eyes
like literally make everything up right
there something they can say yeah no
kind of you know and we get I get
immediate yes or knows versus if I'm
doing it at home or in another say state
one yes or no could take a week or you
know a few days so I like having anybody
in the room so I was literally playing
coming up with something for a cue and
Roger was like what's that what's that I
was like oh I'm making that he was like
that's the ending song and he pointed it
out he's like that's the ending song I
was like okay cool and then I have a
really good friend of mine Mohammad
Ayers he's a great songwriter he's been
working with me for years so I
I sent him the song and me and Mohammed
I think we all discussed a little bit
who we should get to seek the song
because you want to be a powerful song
that's something that people could
really resonate with and they wanted to
be somebody that may be you know certain
certain people no you know I mean Popeye
and Wendy the polettis II and if you
heard the song you know why I got
lettuce you know she's I mean I've known
her for years she's a powerhouse singer
an amazing singer she knows how to tell
stories while she's singing as well and
I know that she's a fan of the Apollo
and watch the Apollo and has been at the
Apollo her saying at the Apollo you know
all of those things so the connections
matter Jane how do you go about editing
are you in partnership with the director
are you kicking the editor and director
out how do you how do you work the
process well I was really lucky that
Roger trusts to me I actually work with
Roger before and he when he approached
me he say gene I will not do this film
with anyone else I was really flattered
I think because I've added Malcolm X
make a plane I edited scottsboro boys so
I have my Africanist I you know he
trusted me I also worked on other music
films so he have full trust in me and
the editing process just really finding
you know what we have we actually the
first day we laid out the timeline on
the wall because from 1934 to long wall
85 it was a very long as there are many
multi layers and you know so many
artists is named like who do we choose
to be in the film and also so the arc I
really also inform us sometimes like you
know we have great James Brown we have
Billie Holiday seeing strange fruit so
it's really sometimes you know the
sparrow come to us and say this is what
you need what was most important to you
um well I'd like to build upon this
timeline because we felt alone a lot of
pressure and I think we still feel a lot
of pressure with this film because
there's a lot of stories we couldn't
tell you know it was a and but was
amazing in the Edit room was the
multiple time
so there was the chronological Apollo
history then there was Harlem history
then there was african-american history
and there was like seminal songs and and
so you start to see this interesting
kind of commentary of the number of
lynchings Billie Holiday having this
opportunity to write and sing strange
fruit and the and how certain timelines
add up you know 1968 and the tumultuous
nosov at Pitt of that year you know with
a tremendous loss as a country that we
experienced and James Brown I'm black
and I'm proud
and what's happening in Harlem and so
this wall became it really certain
moments started really talking to
everyone who was there and in terms of
the process and like what we felt we
needed to highlight Lisa Cortez Robert
Glasper gene Chen the Academy thank you